ce soir au programme vous l'avez vu du
rire de la détente et surtout des
cinémas et pas n'importe lequel
du cinéma vérité à en croire le titre du
film les hommes préfèrent les grosses et
comédie vous vous retrouverez josiane
balasko dans le rôle d'une jeune fille
un peu enrobé qui a du mal à trouver et
à garder un petit ami des recettes de
régime donc où l'humour est roi à 20h45
puis à 22h15 d'un place au coulis du
7ème art avec cinéma cinémas deuxième
vous verrez entre autres patrick
bouchitey sur le tournage de son premier
film une interview exclusive des jarres
depardieu à propos de la nouvelle
version filmée de henry henry 5 et un
plein zoom sur les nouvelles du front et
l'agenda du mois à 20 heures le journal
vous sera présentée par philippe lefait
et dans quelques minutes nous nous
retrouvons car j'ai quelque chose
d'important à vous dire comme comique